après six ans de guerre les
affrontements s'intensifient au yémen ce
vendredi les outils ont réalisé des
avancées majeures en s'emparant d'une
montagne stratégique dans le nord du
pays
objectif des rebelles conquérir la ville
de marib derniers bastions de la région
tenue par le gouvernement yéménite
une progression qui a déclenché une
riposte de la part de la coalition qui
soutient les forces loyalistes
dirigé par l'arabie saoudite celle ci a
mené des frappes aériennes contre les
insurgés
au moins 70 combattants ont été tués
dont 22 des forces gouvernementales et
des dizaines ont été blessées dans les
affrontements ces dernières 48 heures
ces affrontements ont notamment abouti à
la prise du mont ilan par les outils
vendredi les rebelles ont lancé une
attaque violente à cassard a notamment
avec des chars elles a été déjouée grâce
au soutien aérien de la coalition
des bombardements de la coalition qui
ont eu lieu au lendemain d'une attaque
de drones des outils contre une
raffinerie de pétrole à ryad capitale de
l'arabie saoudite une escalade des
violences qui a poussé la russie et
l'union européenne a lancé un appel au
calme
moscou condamne fermement cet acte de
force
nous appelons avec insistance où les
participants au conflit au yémen à
respecter strictement le droit
international et à renoncer
immédiatement et entièrement aux
opérations militaires qui aboutissent à
la destruction des infrastructures
civiles
ces agressions doivent cesser l'escaladé
en cours au yémen et dans ses environs
sape les efforts de l'envoyé spécial de
l'onu
elle retarde la perspective d'une
solution au conflit et accroît
l'instabilité régionale depuis 2015 les
affrontements armés au yémen ont déjà
fait des dizaines de milliers de morts
et provoqué le déplacement de plusieurs
millions de civils une guerre qui a
plongé ce pays pauvre de la péninsule
arabique dans la pire crise humanitaire
actuellement au monde selon les nations
unies